what is happening there reject nation aaron
alexander is back with me we are going to
do a movie reaction first time watching
the film kung fu hustle here's the truth
i think i saw this once when i was like
15 but if you were to ask me what happens
in this movie what is the plot anything
i could honestly not tell you anything
i don't know jack about it oh it's going to be
one of those experiences like even recently i
was re-watching the first season of stranger
things and i was like i don't remember so you
can imagine how i don't remember just more than
15 years i'm like i really don't remember what
happens it's gonna be fresh look all i was trying
to do is remain truthful for you guys however
i think i only thought i saw it because after
doing this reaction i really think this might
have actually been my first time watching
this he's never seen this movie ever this
was recommended to us a bunch and i was like
this sounds like a fun movie so yeah if you
guys can leave a like that'd be very much
appreciated full like watch alongs we stick
up with the time code for kung fu hustle will be
over on our patreon page we cover a whole bunch
of other stuff over there as well subscribe
click that notification while we get notified
when we put up another movie reaction for
something else out there in the meantime
let's enjoy and thanks for the proper boys
for helping us edit these down let's do it
crime busters wow
oh
damn
the axe gang right on axe gang
okay okay leg day
oh
oh wow
bro you got to pick it up a little bit man just
just like four inches you could take a lesson
from him i could bro i'm taking a class
foreign
terrible hustlers
it's fantastic
what the [ __ ]
was an
elephant oh no the real
axe gang is here oh dang it
oh snap
what in the water brothers
oh
dang what are these people
yes the axe call there's such like a sincere
whimsy to this movie it's very creative
oh god oh that's messed up
jesus guys is this maybe gonna stop being funny
i just hope they don't dance after this
someone's got to save him
hello new character
oh my god
oh dang we're all just so
it's talented most badass village i've ever seen
oh
yes
yes he's got the rings baby
oh
great wire works
nice
dang was that his ult
these professional martial artists
just wanted to live in peace
i've always thought about it
sure the ma that's the director of this
movie there's stephen chow oh really
damn y'all gross damn they
could all pee on the same time
y'all got a lot of them impressive bullets
right all pizzas are done creative coordinated
one of those look half eaten already
is that the girl he protected i think i think so
they keep calling her fat she doesn't because
oh snap siren
oh
all right lenny oh my god oh snap
dude
heavens good lord
this is such a strange movie in the best way
look though the roger rabbit world it's like a
cartoon mixed with an actual good kung fu movie
might as well
oh nice
no i like this guy you're screwed i want him to
die you really know anything about him i still
like him he's got some sick moves oh no what you
killed the cat it's got a more lives it's fine
how do you fight these people oh my god
at least you could sense it oh
how do you fight this guy
okay all right just super powers
now we got super strength cool
dad team
ouch ouch ouch ouch
oh my god her screams be counteracted
well now you're screwed what's
gonna do without the strings
no way
the drunken master sleep happy master oh man
okay we just got whole dudes now
i black canary man
oh
yes
i'm rooting for the axe gang
now they're the underdogs
oh don't do that don't do that
uncle donut for donut
actually held on to it after all these years
oh what the [ __ ] dude no it's
the last time i'll be a hero
oh they're going to break that guy out
of those frogs
solo
boy
oh my god
oh wow they're right there
oh shoot that hair though
goddamn okay let's let's stop kicking
let's try to use that scream again maybe
just switch it up guys there it
is okay now we're using our olds
oh he ain't infected at all but oh
oh
god dammit wow
oh this is weakness is he
venom is he allergic to sound
i was like what is she doing
oh my god finally some damage i'm gonna trap him
oh you're screwed no don't listen to him kill him
you admitted defeat dishonorable
oh what a funky position to be
oh my goodness
oh damn
oh phase two of the boss fight
that's a big fist oh
what was your plan here dude
oh
he's the chosen one he's the
butterfly in the beginning
you put that together before
the movie put it together
let's see what you can do you know he's
the protagonist of his goatee shaved off
he's the one he's just
big boy stuff
get up there damn
oh damn
he broke you out to kill you man
he's getting foggy on him
he really is a beast
makes sense where frogs are on the
way to his cell now yeah good catch
this even its final form
oh gotcha on that one with the birdies
yes the power of the buddha you've ascended my man
said then they explained
it right before it happened
oh cool wow
no he's a faker don't do it don't listen to him oh
yeah
oh my god oh my god oh geez
your ear should be
that's neat
everyone come out of your homes now
come on man dead everyone's here alive
oh hmm
pop her in the face
just clean it up just a little bit
kung fu hustle too so what where's the second
one that was fun it was a lot of fun wow
wild whacky adventure all right so here
and i are both pretty hungry right now
starting to keep this short but i feel like it'll
be easy to keep short um yeah you know honestly
i don't even know if i actually saw this because
i was like none of this is familiar to me
so sometimes you know it's like i haven't seen
i remember like not long ago i was with a friend
and he was showing me some kurt russell movie
and then when i was watching i'm like wait a
minute i was like 45 minutes into this going
i think i saw this once when i was a kid
and i didn't actually have that experience at all
here of i think i saw this when i was a kid this
this felt completely brand new to me and even
if i did see when i was younger i don't think i
would have appreciated as much because all like
the types of style and tone and references to
classic hollywood sometimes very overt like
with the fred astaire uh you know poster in
the background the looney tunes inspiration was
very much there and i i loved like how it managed
to infuse it with so much creativity and in a way
that felt earnest it felt sincere like it didn't
feel forced at all in how it wanted to honor all
these different types of styles in a way that felt
natural because a lot of times you could feel like
i get what you're going for but this is kind of
annoying it just didn't annoy me it was always
charming and at times the the fight scenes were
just very impressive and dazzling so it managed
to work on on multiple levels at times feeling
like an anime too i was very much impressed with
this i thought it was a really really fun time
hey ron hi i thought it was really fun too i think
that it is the perfect blend of goofy cartoonery
and uh badass action uh the pacing went by really
fast for me like it was i was hungry the entire
time like i came here straight from work and
it just went by like that it was such a breeze
uh the movie was uh unexpectedly funny
i had no idea how goofy this movie was i
as we were watching it i had like vague childhood
memories of like certain flashes of like of of um
the old like the old woman with like the cigarette
and stuff and like her screaming but i had no
context for anything that was happening and
seeing its entirety was really an experience
that i enjoyed a lot because they're like oh
snap this movie's like wacky and crazy but oh
dang they're like the wire work was insane in this
movie yeah i don't really watch a lot of chinese
movies and old school uh jackie chan stuff so it
was really refreshing it was coming at it for like
it was it's uh it was fresher for me yeah i didn't
i didn't grow up with a lot of it so i'm like wow
such such artistry in the the fighting it's so
amazing i mean it had more of the classic types of
uh peking woo operas what the stuff from like
you and wu ping who did like the matrix films
and um the kill bill the volume one and uh some
other major crowd she's talking to the dragon the
biggest one so yeah like did those movies and it
had some more of that inspiration but i like how
it managed to still stay within sort of feeling
like a cartoon because there were times where
the effects were obviously just very cheap but
charming effects and then at times the effects
were actually pretty cool and how they actually
visually realized a lot of this stuff you know i i
do think that the chosen one element of the story
i was really into the axe gang i was really into
all the the hidden kung fu warriors living out
in that like poor village like the the landlord
or husband that part was really interesting to me
i really loved that story line and i did really
like um stephen chow the main guy i thought like
his performance was really entertaining and i
really was endeared to him at the same time there
was a part of when the chosen one element came in
that didn't quite hit me in the way that i
was sort of hoping it would hit me like it was
cool and maybe it's the fact that we're both also
really hungry so we should have eaten before then
maybe so but there was there was
something about it that felt like
okay yeah it's it's just happening right now
and it wasn't like yes or or exciting or the
i don't know maybe something about the the build
to that was it was obvious it was going to happen
but the build to it didn't feel as maybe cathartic
or rewarding as one would have hoped but needless
to say it was really entertaining it was always i
think the main goal of this movie is to entertain
you and just have fun and i think that it excels
on that on all levels like it never felt like
okay the joke's done or okay the i i'm
used to this now like it managed to still
have surprises throughout and still keep
that inventiveness exciting and i think
at the end of the day if you could pull that
off for 90 straight minutes were because it
was like that thing in the first 20 minutes i'm
like okay this is really fun but we'll just get
will this get boring and it didn't it managed to
remain amusing and entertaining and and thrilling
throughout with some very impressive stuff like
even the way they started eventually infusing like
when they did the reveal of the of the late the
landlord lady her husband i didn't see that coming
with her husband at all like i was like there must
be something with the landlord lady but with her
husband i was like or maybe he's just some normal
dude so that surprises [ __ ] i mean and finding
out a little bit more of that legendary quality
to them like you're that classic you're the
whatever couple they said they are you're
that couple and then also with bringing out
the villain there i thought he was menacing so
there was a lot that i really did enjoy about it
i i thought that this was nothing really i would
change i thought it was like pretty great yeah
yeah i really enjoyed the underdog quality
of all the characters like when you first
meet the people of the village like you really
don't think much of them or especially the scene
where they introduce that element where uh who
the guy who eventually becomes the protagonist is
like yeah i'll take any one from the audience you
see the tall dude and the old woman and then the
little buff ass skater like what the hell so yeah
just all the all the uh protagonists we saw in the
the movie were unexpected heroes and i really
enjoyed that aspect of it and uh yeah i think a
lot of stuff like he was saying was like i really
enjoyed the the couple and and yeah i understand
what you you were saying about the uh the payoff
not feeling very triumphant and that could be in
part for us being hungry but i think part of like
i to be honest i saw the the twist of him being
the chosen one for like maybe like the first 20
minutes of the movie so i was like okay like i
was watching it enjoying the journey and enjoying
his character arc but i was like okay when's he
actually gonna throw down and like be the man he's
gonna be for the finale like at the the moment i
knew that he was the protagonist when uh when
they saw the two dudes like playing the guitar
i'm like oh it's the it's the scoundrel guy he's
gonna be the the hero of the story okay cool yeah
so i i enjoy the story and i enjoy the the action
and i definitely see how um it took both chinese
influences and american influences and smashed
them together in this weird kind of um unexpected
hybrid that kind of gels perfectly together it's
like it's not parody i thought it walked a really
great line between the goofiness of the movie
and the serious aspects of the the drama and the
the pathos of the movie and yeah i think i feel
like it's a very difficult task to achieve but
this movie managed to to do it perfectly there
was never a point where the the goofiness
kind of took me out of the general story of what
was happening yeah but it was it was meant to be
fun like even though you're supposed to have
pathos i didn't feel a lot in this movie but
i don't think it was trying to make me go to
the depths of my soul to feel something so yeah
i guess to close it i have a i had a great time
watching well they did a lot of very inventive it
wasn't just only goofy too i think like the guys
with the piano uh the music the instrumental ones
i thought that was really sinister and inventive
in the way they did that like i've never seen
anything like that in live action ever no most
of this i've never seen in live action ever so
the fact that they managed to do like things that
felt like an anime come to life in a lot of ways i
thought was so damn impressive and it just you
have to find the right tone for something like
this and i think that's what's so impressive is
like they managed to find that like dick tracy
roger rabbit type of vibe but then also
infuse it with this chinese influence
and i i think the thing with the chosen one is
of why this because of why did it hit as much as
because the things that landed some more emotional
impact were always the things that were more
outside with with like the people from the village
and and dealing with the axe gang directly like
the the losses really came from there and then
he would just like check in with the scoundrel
you just check back in with him and you know even
though he got his backstory uh a little bit of
like oh he's actually a good guy at heart i think
maybe it could have just been structured a tad bit
different so that way the the impact could hit a
little bit better or having to be more involved
you know as opposed to just really being on
his own and fighting for the axe gang and
stuff like that yeah there are points where i
forgot he was in the movie i was like oh yeah
yeah like i was never like disinterested
in him i always liked him at the same time
i would be like more interested in with
the other stuff that was going on yeah
versus what was going on with him but it was still
really exciting it was cool like the whole thing
with the palm at the end i thought that was all
[ __ ] awesome the final fight was great but yeah
this was i could see why this this movie still
holds up and why people love it so much because
they they uh to this from 2005 and i still haven't
seen anything like it yeah almost 20 years later
yeah nothing before nothing since i would love to
see a sequel they kind of set up for that i don't
know if that exists or if that's a thing but i
want to watch it now yeah because it was a lot
of fun but aaron thanks for being here man thanks
for having me we'll return for umbrella academy
ladies and gentlemen thanks for being here
subscribe click that bell aaron and i are
going to rush to go stuff our faces right now
because we are starving check us out patreon